dr. Valar good morning and thank you
very much for picking up our call and I
wanted to thank you for everything you
do we have an unusual situation here and
I wanted to ask you an opinion if you
could please share with us okay we have
a young lady family member who had some
trauma going out her life growing up and
she was repeatedly either punched or
kicked in the intestine higher of
stomach in a column and there is a big
possibility that he has she has you know
mr. interests and with respect column
and we would like to hear from you how
can we identify the the right diagnosis
if there is any way to do it without I
mean hopefully the important thing here
is you have to tell me how this past
trauma manifests itself I mean if she
have trouble walking is she in a
wheelchair I mean what is it ramadhan
daughter no no she has she was actually
in and I believe in a fight and she has
the problems with passing out bowel she
has
develop colitis and
occasion issues
question yes
stop stop does she have any history of
respiratory problems any asthma
bronchitis you know
no okay did you have any history of skin
comes any eczema dermatitis arises dry
skin rough skin rosacea
no
okay but you said she has constipation
and how old is she now
she's 26 she's about five five five six
and she's about
160 okay and so no other issues no
diabetes don't how about pressure no
emotional problems no depression okay
Charmaine you there I'm here okay here's
a 26 year old young lady five foot five
five of 660 pounds and she's constipated
she has a history of colitis so they
think maybe from trauma twenty something
years ago from being punished as a kid
she may have a twisted : what do you
think it's going on here well the
obvious thing would be she's got a
gluten intolerance
mm-hmm and maybe
this being beat up as a kid is kind of a
which is a coincidental thing it really
isn't the cause of these problems yeah
constipation colitis goes along with
gluten and being five foot five a girl I
like this here wait 135 140 160 pounds
she's probably 2030 pounds overweight
and so what would you do for her
constipation let's just start for
constipation what would you do there
well
for that issue she could start taking
the herbal rainforest at night one thing
or cleanse yeah yeah she could take the
herbal rainforest said her body weighted
heavily which is a half ounce so one
quart will last two months and usually
within a day or so they'll have a normal
comfortable bowel movement on a daily
basis and
then see here what would you do diet
wise to support healing and absorption
well obviously no wheat barley rye roads
no fried foods over animal fat no oils
of any kind and then that alone should
help a lot and it should also help her
lose the 20 or 30 pounds mm-hmm and then
what program would you give her 160
pounds to again support healthy
physiology healthy biochemical helps and
just her body's want to repair cells
your body requires at 97 nutrients
repair so what where would you go well I
would go personally I would go with a
healthy brain and hard pack for issues
and and then the vitamin d3
yeah and the fact that the fact that she
is 150 pounds that he ever take two
healthy brain or heart attacks or month
you know if it's not a financial issue
to healthy brain a heart attack a month
of full dosage everything twice a day as
you say vitamin d3
in have three of those twice a day two
miles of months and then of course
doesn't hurt for her to take the MSM
just use important promote maintance
repair of connective tissue all over
which would include the walls in the
intestines and so forth and coal
and so give us a call every couple of
weeks if you would Stannis Ladislav you
know give us a call in
two weeks in four weeks in six weeks
less than how this young lady